[Music]
travis is going to start the year off
from asheville north carolina travis
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you guys doing today better than
we deserve man what's
up i have a question for you um we are
in baby step six
um and i made a purchase last month that
i've been losing some sleep about
because i can't decide if i did the
right thing and i tried calling him last
month and y'all were super busy so i'm
getting through today and either going
to get a tongue lashing or some
reassurance i'm not sure but i have a
question about a vehicle i bought
okay
um so i was looking for a truck for
months like two or three months i saved
up cash and with this crazy
market everything that i was seeing just
seemed really high for a used truck so i
kept looking around and i finally came
across a deal a couple hours for me on
the truck that i wanted and it was
actually a new truck that was going for
about three grand less than the used
trucks of the same year like i was
looking at 2019 2020 gmc sierras and
they're going for around 55 grand for
the for the truck that i wanted and i
came across a 2021 that was brand new
with factory rebates that had it down to
about 52.5 and it had to make a quick
move just because of this crazy market
so long story short i did end up
purchasing it even though it was new and
i know that you know that's not what we
do with the baby steps but i'm wondering
what this crazy market and the price you
know and the research that i did if if
this did make sense or if i should look
to maybe get rid of it and get into
something cheaper
well i have a rule i don't start the
year with tongue license
[Laughter]
the first caller of the year we can't do
it it's against one of the rules and so
uh what so you pay 50 grand for a truck
what do you make of your household
income
150 okay
and what's your net worth today
uh about 200 okay
all right
and 50 000 of it is in a truck going
down in value
yes
this is why we tell people not to buy
new vehicles
until you have a million dollars really
worth nothing in five years
right that's the problem with buying new
trucks i mean
if you're worth a million dollars you
can afford to lose 50 grand if you're
worth 200 000 50 grand a lot of your
life
that's the only point so it's not a
tongue lashing it's just an observation
man you're a grown man you make 150
thousand dollars a year you can go buy a
truck if you want to go buy a truck
we're not gonna be mad at you we'll
still be friends
okay
so again no tongue lashings at the first
year but you're right that's why
we teach people
not to yeah and if i was travis i would
have looked at a car that was you know a
few years older than that and that's
where you are going to find something at
a cheaper price point when you look at a
2021 versus the 2022 and the used car
market right now i get that it's crazy
but i think like you're saying dave this
is just a huge percentage of his world
that's tied up in this depreciating
asset yeah i mean the thing is this you
need to ask yourself when you're buying
anything a wheels or a motor
if i set fire to it without insurance
after it finishes burning
is my life changed dramatically
when you lose 25 percent of your net
worth if you set fire to it
that's pretty dramatic
you know it's five percent of your net
worth it's not dramatic
it's a ratio thing for me you can do
what you want to do
but as long as you lean into
depreciating assets being a large chunk
of your world things losing
value that are being a large chunk of
your world then you're going to struggle
with that and i did the exact same stuff
travis i mean we've all done it but you
knew better because you'd been taught
and you just figured out a way to
rationalize it well he was saying if he
wouldn't i wouldn't lose sleep over it
it's not going to cause you to go
bankrupt i'm not going to sit here and
shame you that's not the point the the
point is the reason we teach
not to buy a new car unless you're a
millionaire is this exact reason and it
ca you know it comes from all things
when i got tongue lashed by my grandpa i
mean he passed away now but um you know
he worked 38 years at alcoa aluminum
head cost accounting there in alcoa
tennessee down the mountains east
tennessee and i come wheeling up down
there at
23 years old 24 years old with a million
dollar net worth driving a jaguar
and a bunch of real estate debt coming
out my ears just before i'm going broke
right
and and uh i was all proud of my jaguar
well grandpa from east tennessee didn't
even know what jankwart was he's like
what is his car
and i told him and he's like shaking his
head he was not impressed
and he's like what'd you pay for that
and i told him and he just spit
and he's out of disgust yeah he said a
truck over there didn't cost that and
i'm like no that truck over there costs
200 bucks
you know
and it's not a it's not a fine european
automobile
you know so i drove off all
uh
bothered that my grandpa was not
impressed with my proud new purchase
and uh of course when he passed away he
had a million dollars in money markets
um and so and the reason he did was is
he didn't put it all in things he goes i
said well it's a great car so these
things hold their value and he started
laughing and he goes ain't nothing holds
his valuable wheels on it boy
i said what do you mean he goes like it
holds its value he goes he goes so it's
like an investment he goes my
investments go up
yours go down there's a problem with
this formula they're using son did you
go to college or what you know it's that
kind of thing right one of these
conversations with your grandpa right
nothing like that
whip my butt man oh my gosh
wow too much too much
this is the ramsay show